you're welcome to this video playing
honey foxxx from Austria and I'm need to
check this there's no name in that but
maybe it's one of the guys i played well
I'm not probably not played but it
didn't play an F M from Austria um in
the tournament I played in la mia
fuck'em z ok we have a Ben Oni setup hmm
should I play with a form or play in a
more restrained fashion yeah I always
like to combine f4 with the check on
them on b5 which is just not possible
now of course but it's a it's a been
only where I've got two bishops which
obviously I don't mind however the
question is should I exchange this still
with you should made with Bishop h6 the
bishop on g7 is not a bad piece
and the woman f3 is not doing much
alright so he wants to prepare b5 with
97 and I'm getting rid of this this is a
good piece on gsm so be three or not
young why not it's just blocks it looks
okay f6 wow I'm not sure what this is
doing ok let's try to get the night to
e3 to see form this is the the usual
route right be4 i can take a six and
have the idea to play night c 4 a 5 c 6
this would be a would be excellent
I didn't really get f 6 do you really
want to go to you wants to go to f7 this
looks ugly really ugly under what about
the a6 poor now if you move the rook I
can just take the pawn and yeah
something went wrong there but Knight a5
is not not bad at all I can't just take
this why not 94 just go here protect c2
hmm yeah but the King the king how
Knight takes to e5 category 5 would be
would be very nice to open up the
position can take with the deep on
though well it's not it's not convincing
hmm
okay so activate the Queen go into g4
rh5 maybe h form to to get f5 to get if
maybe five now no first year this is
better and then he five because rook g82
threatens Knight f3 so maybe I need to
spend a temper King edge one they are th
one doesn't doesn't hurt any way to do
that move okay night 87 on a rock a 7 or
not it's better on a 786 if 5 i'd like
to play you five activate my my my
bishop of course
hmm not really not really possible
I don't really see how to make a
substantial progress here I was trying
to play 427 rock t cell
nice he's weakening the sea por now as
well okay maybe just try to get into the
end game with Roxy 7 Wow
group g2 Queenie 7 rock the eight though
rock the eighth maybe I can play rock
the ATM but I can take is Sapna g7 group
d 7 rock d 7 now it's not working it can
play back the eight what a shame Rock g2
I can take it just is happenin turned
when but rocked yet i will create i
could have just played Queen s3 and keep
all my classes I'm still upon up look
dad no and I don't really have a move
hmm ok so just the end game or Jack K
come on let's let's head for this end
game it's not not bad for wide
takes on b3 I take at five
can take on you for but I just just
capture maybe 9 p-5 huh you can play if
i take here takes tags now this is
winning I can take deform takes d3 take
c5 and my rook will stop the D problem a
pause / mode okay if he takes on e4 I
take default yeah wow I wanted to go
here but I completely forgot that you
got two pawns he's got two pawns
you
I think it's it's still winning but wow
maybe not we'll get through here hmm
look at three
probably need to cover that check check
time morning I cannot go to him to check
rendering d7 what the heck don't believe
that black market oh yeah not only them
lost even right yeah one on time but I'm
lost you I completely completely forgot
that he's got two pawns I thought okay
I'll stop the deep one easily but he's
got the ippo on as well so this earth
this wasn't great oh it is winning
actually but not how I played it
I c6c 630 67 this is winning yeah and
this is now very tricky at least and
maybe it's a even even worse for me yeah
this was a rather unnecessary of course
Kim Ji Won maybe I don't know this is
just winning here for what but maybe c3
was a bit too a bit too too direct I
mean it's maybe maybe winning
technically as as we see as we saw with
this c6 and c7 but I don't really want
to give him that much play alright
thanks for watching